if we only have a finite time in this
solar system well what are we doing to
eventually get ready at some point we
have to go it's not if we go it's when
we go and so i want to think about what
can we do technically ethically and
really sociologically to do to make that
happen
christopher mason welcome to the show
pleasure to be here thanks for having me
do you know how i knew that me and you
were going to get on just fine it's when
i found out that you were also a fan of
neil stephenson's seven eves
yes uh the five books review probably
you read i imagine yes yes
which was uh if your audience hasn't
read it is really a phenomenal book but
is also terrifying in a lot of ways but
i think it it is related to some of the
things that i just wrote in my book yeah
in terms of thinking about what happens
at the cusp of survival for our species
and what do we do and how do we survive
so yeah it's a great book
i'm sure it will be a movie at some
point too it has to be it's basically
written as if it's already oh good the
first line the moon explodes yeah the
first line of the book the moon explode
so anyway like how how do you get
started
thinking about creating a road map for
us to leave earth
it comes from really a place of hope i
actually think the i'm a humanist i i
like people there's a lot of things that
people do bad but there's a lot that we
do that's great in terms of poetry and
music and science and the ability for
humans to
create things that will exist long past
their own lifetime and so i mean the
most obvious example is people have kids
all the time
but even historically when people build
cathedrals that we knew would take
generations to build uh and also even
just having science projects that can
sometimes be multi-generational climate
change is a good example we you know
we're not doing it that well yet and we
could do it wrong there too but uh there
are many places where
humanity has a lot that i think that is
extraordinary and i think it's worth
preserving as long as possible so i've
always thought that and as i became a
scientist i thought well if we're really
going to
exist as humans for a long long time
we have to think about what is that time
and then how do we do it and the time
frame i think about a lot is the the end
of the earth because well once you read
about that it's going to happen and
that's something i never forgot so i
think well if we only have a finite time
in this solar system well what are we
doing to eventually get ready at some
point we have to go it's not if we go
it's when we go
uh and so i want to think about what can
we do technically ethically
and uh really sociologically to did you
make that happen
the timeline has actually been moved up
a little bit sooner as well right
originally most people think that we've
got about four billion years until the
sun's going to expand and engulf the
earth but in
less than one billion years it'll be
getting pretty hot a lot of oceans will
evaporate and life's going to be very
very difficult so the timeline has been
hurried along to say the least
yeah absolutely so this is and i
actually got really sad when i was
writing the book at the end i thought
well i'm writing kind of like what
happens in the far far future for
humanity or what could happen what i
hope happens and it i always have that
number in my head like well we have you
know four and a half billion years is a
long time and a billion years is still a
pretty long time too but it was the
equivalent of imagining that you might
live to be a hundred years old and
someone telling one day no you're only
going to beat it 20. that's you're gonna
have about a fifth of the lifespan you
thought you would have because by then
the as you just said the oceans will
begin to boil the luminescence of the
sun gets so so much more that it gets
probably too hot to live here we could
maybe live underground but it's going to
be tough
so i got really sad i came downstairs
and told my wife i was like oh i just
and she's like what's wrong and i said
well i just thought we had more time and
she said you know a billion years still
a long time
i said yeah it is but it's certainly a
lot less than i thought we had so i was
a bit sad finishing the book and
thinking about it but it underscores the
fact that that's the maximum time right
it assumes we don't have an asteroid hit
us some other global global calamity you
know some plague for example we just had
a plague so something else could happen
and really decimate humanity before then
and i find that said because as i state
we i think we have an ethical obligation
to preserve not only our species but all
life that we can see because we're the
only ones that knows it can become
extinct and so this gives us a unique uh
responsibility because we're the only
ones that is aware of it just dig into
that a little bit more for me please
because you talk about ecosystems and
there's these typical sort of three
groups of of animals and then you kind
of class us as this fourth species sort
of a
a guardian
of the earth galaxy type thing yes it is
kind of like a guardian of the galaxy so
i i recognize that is a great comic book
that's been around for decades and now
movies and it is but it's interesting in
the original comic books i've actually
never read them but i've seen some of
the movies but i've now since read some
of them uh after the my books come out
and after seeing some of the movies they
uh it's similar concept is that the
they're guarding you know truth and
justice and and sort of the nature of
the universe and life but some of the
concepts are the same where we need in
some sense protectors uh of life in the
universe and quite literally guardians
of the galaxy so i actually really
wrestled with what would be the best
term when i was writing it is well are
we are we shepherds are we
sherpas are we guardians are we
protectors what's the best word and
guardian's the best thing i could come
up with because it describes what our
role is is to really serve as protectors
uh of of life itself and the complexity
of life to which again as far as we know
is unique in the entire universe
so far
and so i i think you know those three
the three things people normally think
of are producers consumers uh and
decomposers like in the environment
there's either something eating you or
you're eating it or it's decomposing you
basically and throughout all of history
that's what we kind of view all
ecosystems as but i think
uh for us we are we we can see the
ecosystem we understand its fragility
and we can actually protect it which no
other entity can do
that's been previously described so i
think we are distinct and i would hope
that even if ai takes over someday they
would also have sentience and might view
the value see the value of complexity of
thought or life or in any matter whether
it's carbon-based or otherwise so i talk
about that a little bit too that i'm i'm
agnostic towards matters complexity if
it's a carbon-based silicon based
hopefully they all have the same sense
of guardianship
it's interesting because
the hubris that can be quite quickly
attributed to thinking that we're
supposed to be in charge of
this little corner of the universe
it is quite an easy accusation to make
who do we think that we are the planet
was fine before we got here the planet
will be fine after we leave well
no it won't there's a lot of existential
risks for us to get past and even if we
make it past all of them there is this
huge full stop coming at the end of the
sentence and that's going to be the sun
uh
it's it's really interesting to think
about whether or not
well i i just like the fact that we are
the only corner of the universe that
appears to have illuminated it with
consciousness and we are not
cargo aboard spaceship earth we're crew
and we can actually direct its
and everything else that's on it right
we can save the rest of the cargo and i
think from that
naturally you run forward with this is a
compulsive duty this provides us with a
level of responsibility that we need to
bear
seriously
because we're the only ones that can and
to your point some people say
you know i think
we're just going to screw it up as the
most common response i guess they're
going to do it better than the [ __ ]
tigers do give me a break come on or
or better than you know the sun is not
going to be a good shepherd it'll engulf
the whole planet right so
it is that's the thing that to me it
derives from a simple it's a
cosmological fact like it's not my
opinion that we need to eventually leave
this planet like until we can survive in
a fusions you know state with the sun as
entities and if unless that happens we
have to leave so it's not a might we
should we can we we and everything else
on here is gone and so i think and
there's even some people who push back
on that more and say well maybe it
should just be extinguished maybe all
life should be extinguished
anyway yeah and they and they're not
even taken by the uh this because it
presupposes an inherent value of life
right which some people still could
reject and say well life is there's
matter over here and there's matter over
there is life really that special and
and i still
which i i think is is somewhat axiomatic
that i shouldn't have to you know make
that obvious to someone it seems pretty
straightforward but even there when i've
debated this with some philosophy
professors and other people just on the
street sometimes
to convince them i see that there is an
ability to you know serve as the
self-awareness and serve as these
caretakers that no other matter can do
like i think it actually the reason i
think it's hopeful is because it pushes
away this indifferent state of most of
the matter in the universe yeah and it's
something that does have a concern which
i think has value at the very least for
survival it's just self self um interest
but it is
it's you know it's projecting our you
know our ability on other species and it
does involve hubers but the hubris
doesn't obviate its necessity i think
well we locally reverse entropy right in
our current state we actually make a
little bit of order from chaos and
that's really cool like if
even if you were to take a really
fundamental view and say there's nothing
particularly special about life you
would say well
we
tend to take care of more unique
environments because we understand that
there is something inherently special
about that by its very nature there is
more that isn't that than that that is
so therefore you look across the entire
galaxy as far as we've seen and as of
yet we have to presume that we are the
only
section of the universe that has a green
planet that's got life that's able to be
intelligent and so on and so forth so
yeah i mean you can be as axiomatic as
you want and try and take it back to
first principles but like
regardless of your value for human life
this corner of the universe simply seems
to be more unique than others and
therefore why wouldn't you protect it
right right it's among literally the
most unique thing in the universe is
what we're what we are and what we're
standing on and so that at least is is
interesting and i think worth protecting
and uh and to your and i mentioned this
also in the book that there's you could
argue gravity somewhat reduces entropy
by bringing things together and as most
people probably know the second law of
thermodynamics entropy will just always
probably increase unless the universe
ends in a big collapse
uh there again from gravity so that's
what eventually bring the entropy back
all together but
short of gravity the only other thing
that organizes matter in a in a negative
entropy fashion is life itself right so
it is extraordinary that we're out and
we're doing it in our cells you have to
ask ourselves to put together peptides
to make proteins to synthesize dna to
sort of so for the ride man
they're just doing all the microbes in
this and honest you know they're doing
all their their jobs uh it is
extraordinary and and we're just at the
tip of the iceberg of what we've learned
about the complexity of life about
chemistry it's adaptability our ability
to even engineer life or even just
understand the basic genetics of life
it's just really getting started in the
past couple decades so the part of the
enthusiasm of the book is
we're really at this really the launch
has just started like the engines of
discovery have just been on for a couple
decades and have already found
extraordinary things so
it was exciting to write what's
deontogenic ethics
so i tried to frame this in the book as
as a principle of uh because i really
want to make it a moral argument is that
why should we do this and we just kind
of covered some of this of course but i
think i've been really taken by this
ever since i took a philosophy class in
college is that there's historically
been
two views of ethics and one is uh
basically the um
emmanuel kant's categorical imperative
which is the you know imagine if
something that you did became a rule for
everybody how would the world look and
then you imagine the world and think
would this be good or bad most common
example is if you steal a candy bar when
you're a kid your mom will say well you
shouldn't steal a candy bar i think if
everyone stole a candy bar then there'd
be no candy bars and you think okay i
get it so even a kid can understand that
but this is also sometimes contradicted
or battled with uh utilitarian ethics
which is the greatest good for the
greatest number we try to calculate what
does one action do and the consequences
of it as well as what other people are
doing and try and get to a place of you
know the greatest good for greatest
number overall uh there's a lot of
challenges with both those ethical
frameworks is you know how do you
measure uh what some actions might do if
only some of the population does it or
whatever the greatest good for greatest
number how do you quantify the good or
the bad and it depends on where you are
and who you are of course
uh and even there's there's what's the
consequence of reaction not the intent
and so there's a lot of ethical
challenges but
that is the backdrop i kept thinking
what's what's something that's before
all of that i think the most essential
duty uh and one thing i like about kant
is he talks a lot about what is our duty
to other humans i think we actually have
a duty that even is antecedent towards
our duty to each other which is a duty
just to do it the existence itself like
you can't have an ethical debate if
you're not alive to have it so i think
the duty uh precedes it as to just for
existence as i'd like to say existence
precedes the essence of anything you
want to do
so our genetic duty our like our duty to
propagate ourselves as well as to ensure
livelihood of the things on which we
depend uh is the minimal duty just to
survive so it's a it's a genetic duty
part one the other part of it though is
once you realize that and you're
self-aware as a species as we are you
then have a duty towards i think serve
as their protectors because once you've
become a works of extinction you can
then actuate it or you can prevent it
and so i think uh this is the the other
part of the genetic duty is to preserve
the complexity of life and life itself
and so i i frame that out as duties that
are even before any other duty because
uh everything else depends on them so um
i call the deontogenic or the the
genetic uh duty basically and the
ethical framework around that
cool i'm proposing an entirely new
ethical framework because why not i
don't know i just [ __ ] i mean you're
also trying to get us to another star
system within half a millennia so just
re-write rewrite everything else about
ethics as well at the same time all
right so
what's the end goal to go take me 500
years into the future what are you
hoping that we're able to do
so if all goes well and as described you
know in fun and and
little just parts of the book are kind
of playful where i talk about green
humans that have chloroplasts in their
skin and it could be big huge plants
which is fun to write about in that and
that calculations that would necessitate
the changes to cells so at the end of
all that uh i'm hoping that we have
what's interesting in the book i don't
presume any advances in necessarily
propulsion or genetics beyond what we
know today with things that actually
work today that we've deployed in
clinical trials that exist uh in
astronaut studies that we're doing as we
speak
so just small extensions of what we're
doing or small tweaks and then project
reasonably 500 years out i believe that
we would have enough knowledge of the
risk to the body and ways to mitigate
them and even to repair cells or to even
genetically protect the cells we'll come
back to that that you could survive the
trip out through interstellar space to
another planet and actually we'll have
enough exoplanets discovered that we
would be able to know where to go and so
at the end of 500 years i hope that we
will have done testing and then begin to
send people out on what are called
generation ships which actually is a 100
year old idea what if multiple
generations live and die on the same
ship on their way to a new star
but 100 years ago or even 20 years ago
it was pure science fiction because we
knew of we had no good substrate of
genetics to understand or we only had a
handful of exoplanets discovered all of
them impossible for life as we know it
today
but today we already have several
hundred planets that are likely
habitable exoplanets meaning outside of
our solar system we have a pretty
in-depth knowledge of human genetics and
microbial genetics and ways to modify
cells to keep them alive to resist
radiation to maybe get new tweaks and
even new
abilities
and i describe a lot of them in the book
and so it means after 500 years i think
we would have really and we're basically
on phase two of the 500 plan the first
10 years just finished and i wrote about
kind of this is a template about when i
started my lab and we just finished
phase one which which won quite well i'd
say the first 10 years have gone quite
swimmingly i'll be dead for the vast
majority of that 500-year plan i'll
probably die around somewhere between
age 80 to 110 maybe somewhere in there
i'm guessing if all goes well you know
but but then at that point we'll be able
to head towards a new star and and
hopefully then become not just
interplanetary but interstellar in our
state
who's the architect that built that
cathedral in barcelona that's still
being built now
um you know i don't know which one you
think so it's huge it's this huge
beautiful cathedral anyway it's this
really famous artist whose name escapes
me i want to go and see it and do the
tour which shows how bad my memory is uh
and he's done the same thing that you've
done he created this ridiculously long
elaborate plan and then a hundred years
after his death everyone's still having
to adhere to it and they're all still
away doing the work and he's long gone
he's chilling um or even the for the
first uh the lease for the land where
the guinness brewery was the first lease
that was signed uh by alec by senator
because by guinness the first brewer was
for 9 000 years they said i want a 9 000
year lease and they gave it to him they
said okay uh sure
you know the br the beer is still being
brewed there so uh we've only been you
know 150 years or something like
8 850 years still to go yes it's a lot
of guinness
well done granddad all right so
what how much does space wreck the human
body
it's it's unpleasant especially in the
first few days and where the astronauts
get what's often called puffy phase
where they look uh a lot basically
because your body is built to push fluid
you know essentially uh up because
you're used to having gravity trying to
push it down so it has to keep
circulation going suddenly you don't
have that downward force so generally
about two liters of fluid goes from your
legs and lower torso to your upper body
which makes you kind of puffy and uh
essentially eventually the lymphatic
system and the body adapts and you get
mostly back to normal but there's you
know just
lymphatic and sort of fluid shifts
changes as soon as you get up into space
sorry just inject that man like isn't
that crazy the fact that no human in all
of history ever went to space
ever existed in zero gravity
and yet
our body is able to adapt itself like it
takes a bit of time and you look like a
basketball for a little while or
whatever but
that's so [ __ ] cool it's amazing and
i think
we uh and
the adaptability and plasticity of the
body is extraordinary and and so that
writ large it's rough on the body but
the body recovers we saw this with scott
kelly with other astronauts we've
published a study on 59 astronauts just
a few months ago
and you know everyone has a different
reaction to it we can see some people
have huge spikes of cortisol as soon as
they get into space and you can see the
body kind of freaking out saying holy
crap i'm in space
hence that motion of i'm used to gravity
the history of my entire species is used
to gravity and i don't have any right
now so what the heck
but the body adapts and then we can see
some people have the spike in cortisol
and then it comes right back down
actually scott kelly was cool as a
cucumber after the first couple days but
other astronauts have the spike and it
stays pretty high so they actually
uh are still kind of adapting and you
know scott is a veteran uh astronaut
kelly has been up there four five times
now
and he uh you know so some of this i
think he's gotten used to it but it is
extraordinary that the body can get into
a situation it's never seen before and
adapt quite well a great example of this
though is even our adaptive immune
system like we can see a pathogen that
our body by definition is new and has
never seen before
and you know essentially interact with
it engage it digest it create t cells
and antibodies that will recognize it
and then be ready for when they see it
again so it's really this beautiful
component of by of human biology and
many other species that have adaptive
immune systems to be so responsive to
the environment
and we did it because we had to because
there's because the microbes reproduce
faster than we do and they're mutating
faster because they have crappier
polymerases that copy their dna or rna
so
we kind of had to make it that way but
any case so what the
the question of what happens to the body
you have a lot of the fluid shifts and
the body uh adapts to that there is
increased radiation there's of course
you're in a more isolated space you're
in place with less people so there's
changes in your microbial environment
there are just hazards cognitively
you're in a very stressful environment
again far from friends and family
and and it it's uh so it's it's it's
tough on the body but the two biggest
things we worry about are the change in
gravity fields and then also the um the
radiation so and it's important to say
it's not that there's really technically
zero gravity because there's still
plenty of gravity you're just at the
place where you're falling with the
space station at the same rate uh so it
feels like zero gravity but you still
have gravity you're just falling so
technically it's called change in
gravity fields you could say as i was
experienced
so those are the two big things that
drive a lot of the changes and so what
happens is your microbes change in your
gut we see a lot of spikes in the genes
that activate for the immune system
especially as soon as you get up there
the body they just think that you're
under attack you'd see it basically all
this molecular signatures appear as if
the body's on high alert thinks it's
maybe attack an infection it's not clear
but a lot of the same signatures for
those medical events spike up when you
get into space and even more so when you
get back to earth and and a lot of these
same what are called cytokines which are
these molecular kind of signals that
cells send to each other about what's
happening and should they launch a
response an immune response for example
these are heavily activated in flight
and then also when you get back to earth
so that is a consistent feature we've
seen for all the astronauts this kind of
immune sort of uh signature and stress
and even you know there's because of
that stress it's not necessarily good or
bad it really depends on the astronaut
because your immune system being on high
alert could be good because then you
actually uh could could you know adapt
and be aware for any potential pathogen
the bad thing though is if your immune
system starts to attack itself
essentially this is what autoimmune
disease diseases uh can do
uh and and really wreak havoc on the
body we don't see that for astronauts
but just just to make the point that
just having uh activation of everything
is not necessarily a good thing but it's
not necessarily bad either and we've
seen for
a lot of things that changed in flight
they almost all went back to normal
within a few months being back on earth
in terms of the genes the microbes these
cytokines these things that change they
all were pretty relatively quickly back
to normal
in a matter of either days
or or
weeks and in some cases a few months but
the other thing for example telomeres
got longer in space so these little
these these still basically book ends at
the end of your chromosomes that keep
your dna packaged and safe they actually
got longer in space which at first we
thought was maybe just something weird
about astronaut kelly
but now we've seen it in every astronaut
we've looked at has worked with susan
bailey uh so far it's 12 out of 12 for
the astronauts that we've looked at
they're telling us get longer in space
we think it's two things that are
driving this is that they there is a
little bit of consistent low dose
radiation that they're experiencing
which we've seen if you do this for
other organisms like uh malaria
plasmodium falciparum their telomeres
also get longer if you do low dose
radiation
uh which they live in
uh they don't
they don't live no they did not because
eventually it went away but after the
radiation was stopped it went back so
it's two things it's a bit of a response
to the cells to turn on telomerase to
elongate elongate the the actual
telomeres and also we think it's killing
out the low dose radiation is going to
kill out and remove some of the cells
that were close to dying anyway so that
your average telomere length goes longer
because you're getting rid of the cells
that we're about to have the shorter
telomeres anyway so it's those two
things together
but then it goes back to normal you know
once you get back uh from space then you
know then it goes quickly right back
normal that's an interesting one that's
like a radiation hormesis effect thing
that you've got going on there almost
that you stripping away the the unused
ones all right what's the longest that
anyone's ever spent in space
in a single go in a single there was a
cosmonaut who did it i believe it was
540 days is the record uh if they double
check that but i believe it was it was a
cosmonaut so the record holder so scott
kelly went up for 340 days there was uh
the longest is about a year and a half
or it was around 540 days if i recall
was a cosmonaut and so that is the
the human record so far but there are
plans afoot to try and break that record
in the next four or five years if all
goes well roll the clock forward for me
what you've identified so far and the
challenges that those astronauts have
faced in cosmonauts uh i don't want to
be anglo-centric um
there's some chinese astronauts now yes
um
that
these people that go into space have had
to face that's limited to a year and a
half let's double that or say three
years to sort of ten years is there
something that you can predict that's
going to be a challenge
for people to face in space there that
doesn't manifest within a year and a
half
this is a great question something
that's like endlessly debated at nasa
meetings um
aerospace meetings medicine meetings
is because
you know the short answer is i think i
think we'll have seen already most of
the significant changes that occur in
flight or to the body from this year and
year and a half long missions
uh truth be told we don't know there
might be something that only gets really
bad when you've been in zero g or you
know loss of gravity
for
two years or three years and it's just
some unique feature you know i don't i
don't i can't think of what that would
be but it's hard to speculate on
something we've never observed before so
it is a it is a extrapolation and it's
imperfect but i think we've seen
most of what the body does uh in space
flight and what we'll likely see again
for longer missions but we just think
we'll see more we do see damaged dna for
example coming out in urine so you can
see fragments of the dna coming out you
can see calcium you can see the loss of
bone density in it's coming out of the
body almost if it's you know being uh
you know just excreted away it's really
like just you can see the law so it's
really striking to see that loss just
coming out of the body so i think we'll
just see more of those i don't think
we'll suddenly see dramatically new
differences in the urine that we're
getting and the molecules in the urine i
hope but we'll find out soon enough
presumably further and further away from
the sun as well less magnetic protection
less magnetic protection from the earth
from radiation from solar flares from
other bits and pieces like that
big bursts of radiation as you get
further away from our solar system
that's par for the course yep it would
be a bigger problem so the van allen
belts are we're living in this wonderful
protective magnetosphere and once you
get outside of that
uh you're you're much more you're at
risk and so there's a lot of space
weather satellites and researchers that
are constantly tracking sunspots and
solar activity hopefully we could warn
some of the astronauts before it were to
hit them because we have enough time uh
before it would get there
uh
but you know you know but even there if
they go into a slightly more protected
chamber of a spacecraft it's not going
to be like under living under 20 feet of
rock or something right so it's going to
be
uh limited protection but we're hoping
you know there are ways to do
electromagnetic protection um and some
things to talk about in the book are
genetic protection tools where you can
activate genes temporarily for example
dna repair genes and then turn them back
off and so again this is not yet being
tried in humans it's mostly just in cell
lines and in animal models but we know
that technically it's possible and it
would have to be really rigorously
demonstrated in clinical trials for
safety and efficacy but at least we know
conceptually it's possible to do such a
defense your suggestion is to
kind of
add in either genetic modifications or
epigenetic modifications can be switched
on and switched off kind of in the same
way as at the moment people that go to
space have uh protective suits so you
need a particular augmentation to you as
a human in order to survive a
non-typical environment and
your suggestion from genetics
is just to provide the same but
internally as opposed to externally
why do you think
this is a very
touchy subject for people is it just
naturalistic fallacy is it something
sacred about the current human nature
uh both are both are active threads of
thought where people say
uh you should never adjust the natural
world because if it's natural it's
perfect uh although as we've already
described earlier if it's natural and
it's and it's only staying here it will
not be perfect it'll be gone so smallpox
wasn't too good either yeah
and and yeah no one has problems saying
let's eradicate uh severe pathogens like
no one's saying save the covid right
that's not happening
there are certain times where we decide
and rightly that there is a deontogenic
framework that's being violated by
another organism right in this case if
some organism is inhibiting the ability
of another organism to live at all or
just especially to serve as guardians or
shepherds of other life forms then that
is uh is is bad in that ethical
framework it is something that you
should remove you're actually doing the
right thing by getting rid of a
existential threat to you now you have
to balance that because sometimes a
threat to one organism is helping for
another so there are places where it's
much more complicated and there may even
be some place where smallpox is helpful
to something somewhere but not that we
know of but you have to make the value
judgment and i know that the deontogenic
framework it's a no-brainer it's really
easy to say oh that we is is uh
ethically bad
and so the net the natural
some of the the pushback on it is you
know how how could we make sure it's
safe how can we make sure that you know
that this is uh efficacious which but we
do this all the time with clinical
trials for car t cells or various
chimeric antigen receptor therapies
where we modify t cells infuse them into
patients we do this at the hospital i'm
at now as well as other many others i'm
working with
this is just part of clinical trials you
do it slowly do it carefully you make
sure before you roll out any therapy
that it has really met good clinical
guidelines and that the benefits
outweigh any of the possible risks uh
and so we're not there yet at all for
some of these therapies i described in
the book but but we're pretty close on
other ones we're massively modifying and
crisper editing cells and then putting
them back into patients uh to cure
disease in some cases extraordinarily
well so i think what's the most
successful case of that that you think's
happened so far
one of the so outside of the the
immunotherapies where you have modified
t cells or natural killer cells that
then grown up and reinfused back in some
of them crispered or otherwise modified
with other receptor changes
those are really extraordinary talk
about those for a while in the book but
then some of the other therapies these
epigenetic therapies where you can even
turn back on a gene uh inside you that
had been turned off previously so one of
the best examples of this is treating
for sickle cell disease uh it might even
be useful for beta thalassemia is
basically there you have hemoglobin is
wrong is faulty your adult hemoglobin
has a problem so the concept for the
therapies which are being in in the
clinic now is well okay when you're a
fetus when you're much younger you did
have fetal hemoglobin which is a
different kind of molecule that carries
oxygen actually much better really than
adult hemoglobin but it gets turned off
when right after you're born and it just
stays off so for the rest of your life
you have this other version of a gene
that makes hemoglobin that's just
sitting there kind of quietly
and
yeah late and then what you do is
actually now you can get rid of the
enhancer that's controlling it keep it
off and then you turn it back on it's
actually been in clinical trials looks
like it's extraordinarily successful
because you get a good version of the
gene back activated so i think this idea
say if you did that for certain genes
for for dna repair that you that might
be useful for space flight uh
you know again it's just a different
gene target it's just in a different
environment but here we'd say because we
think the risk is so great that this
benefit would overcome that uh so that's
one of my favorite examples and it's
really you know it depends on things
again 20 years ago would be science
fiction we didn't even know all the
genes in the genome where they were what
they were we kind of had a first draft
not really
the tools the technology to do this
editing also were very nascent uh and
now you can crisper things that when we
have high school students doing crisper
it's uh you can almost crisper in your
kitchen if you want to you actually can
there's home kits you can if you want to
so it's crazy it's an amazing time are
you working with dr david sinclair on
this uh a bit actually on some of the uh
we've chatted a bit on some of the
longevity uh uh basically cells he's
looking at so looking at the epigenetic
changes to what happens for some of the
treatments he's thinking yeah so we
we've actually been back-to-back at like
three conferences recently where we end
up just being in the agenda
uh and usually i'll speak first and say
here's what we need to do for the next
five hundred years and then he'll say
and here's how i hope we'll live
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
a fun pairing actually at conferences
recently it's been fun great he's a good
mate he's um the work that he's doing is
fantastic it's so cool to see that so
yeah the thing that i've got in my head
around people that may have a challenge
to do with gene editing is a combination
of ignorance about the fact that we're
already doing it um an anchoring bias
against what we have right now and not
understanding what could be
that
fixing something that's wrong i.e a
change of the status quo isn't the same
as improving something that we don't
have but that just comes down to how do
you judge welfare and then it's just
scope neglect it's just not
understanding what the outcome could be
if we don't get this right and this is
something from reading toby ord's the
precipice
that really sort of force-fed me and
understanding
if you fully see yourself as a steward
of humanity and as someone that's
supposed to leave the world in a better
place than when you found it you can't
just be thinking globally you need to
think pan generationally so it's not
just about everybody on the planet right
now it's everybody on the planet forever
and everybody that could then come from
the planet thereafter as well so yeah i
think when you when you fully
internalize that any argument that isn't
we need to do everything that we can
to gobble up as much
galactic real estate as is possible and
to make ourselves right for that kind of
by whatever means we can and it's
interesting that the sort of deontogenic
argument
um you need to have something more
concrete to hold on to because you get
into questions of what are we saving
you know how far can we change ourselves
while still being ourselves is a
question that you inevitably end up
encountering and i suppose that sort of
human values the fundamentals of what we
are to be human the genetics so on and
so forth kind of that's the
the ground the the foundation upon which
everything else grows out
it it is but also it can change i would
say
i mean the the idea that there's a
perfect state that humanity is now uh is
fallacious right and it's just not true
the humans
are in a state where we are now
whatever this is but it's by it always
changes it and it will continue to
change evolution is not static so it
we're all evolving as we speak right
best example recently is that now we can
drink milk as adults but 20 000 years
ago we probably probably couldn't anyone
could or barely could so the selection
for pretty interesting adaptive trade
for adults based on diet is is really
recent and interesting even just uh you
know how people have different hair eye
and skin color is a reflection of a few
hundred thousand years of migration
around the planet has already led to
really dramatic changes so
we're continuing to evolve and i think
that even if we evolve to a place where
there's literally a different species
like say someone there's people on mars
for twenty thousand years and said at
some point they can no longer reproduce
with people on earth that may happen but
it's not necessarily a bad thing they're
just more people and also i described in
the book a concept of planetary liberty
or even the cellular liberties that
you're no longer subject to the whims
of the genetic
deal that you got as an embryo you can
fix things that are broken or even
modify things that you want improved
very much as a right as what your
genetic rights are as an individual is
that you should have full autonomy and
control
over your dna
which doesn't really exist uh in most
legislatures or in sort of any laws
anywhere but we do we have versions of
this we have reproductive rights we have
rights about privacy we think about this
a lot in you know in current laws but
nothing about the right to do something
with your own cells or your own dna but
i think that very much is your right and
this includes
the ability to live on more than one
planet so if you do your genome editing
accurately and and correctly and broadly
you'll increase your planetary liberty i
would actually think it would be sad if
you had to engineer humans so much that
you send them to mars like okay good
congrats you can live on mars now we've
made it so you're perfectly suited for
it but you can never come back to earth
i would find that to be a technological
failure we would we should if possible
expand the number of places on which you
can live including planets uh that's an
expansion of liberty liberty gives you a
choice to do anything you'd want and so
if we do it right you could you know
expand the planetary liberty essay or
cellular liberty of which planet you can
live on
why should we take a bath in yogurt
ah so i um find it to be very soothing i
describe that there's some little
nuggets in the book that come up here
and there like taking a bath in yogurt i
uh i i have coated myself in yogurt uh
it sometimes be um obviously a
recreational thing
i do it when i'm hungry and i want to
sit in a bathtub involve something i
find a bathtub full of yogurt is great
you can uh you know dip a spoon in and
then just eat it uh bathtub full of
barbecue sauce is even better i highly
recommend it or maybe uh i could think
of you know um other sauces maybe in the
uk you could think of um you know not
hot sauce though i imagine that's
probably
it's tough on the mucous membranes i i
don't remember that i don't recommend
that yeah
so you talk about humans that could have
green skin and about this
other different ways that we could try
and modify our dna so that we can
survive in space what i think is a more
interesting question than that or at
least for me are the ethics around what
it means to travel for a long time
is it ethical to say
that
you can make a decision to go on a
generation ship
and
impound
the next 20
generations of your progeny to live to
be born to live and to die
all within a metal can that's floating
from a deontogenic ethics framework it
is 100 ethical because it is what
enables us to survive long term along
those goals
so that it's easy easy for me to say yes
and that assumes though that that's what
the goal of the generation ship is
there's a chance that maybe the ship
would fail and you get to the new planet
and it turns out not to be as good as
you think and then everyone perishes
that would be really unfortunate but
would still represent an ethical
decision to have made that choice on
that mission with the information you
had at the time so i think
but it raises questions of consent and
by definition the children and
grandchildren in that mission get zero
consent over 20 generations
but you know but here too we uh we
there's two two things i'd say to that
is uh you know when people say well how
how can you do this one is i'd say uh
it's ethical but the two other responses
i'd add to that are is we people do this
all the time parents move across the
world to find a new place when they're
when children are babies and the babies
don't need consent to move say from you
know tennessee to alaska and live up in
a cold tundra uh the parents at some
point just have to decide that's part of
what parents do
and you know
the other thing is we're already kind of
on a big generation ship now like you
can't go to another planet right now
we're just on earth it's a really big
generation ship that's wonderful and
nice and has lots of features
but this is a big ship that you can't
leave that you're on right now it's just
called earth and uh so it's not really
that different in terms of type of of
trip that we're taking it's just a
difference of uh of the size of i'd say
yeah i agree it isn't a different of
kind it's a difference of degree but the
difference of degree from an
individual's level is it's a very very
large price to pay yeah for sure you
know you didn't ask to be here you
didn't ask to be put on this ship you
know
we need some serious advances in
entertainment technology in order to be
able to make a ship as fun as earth is
it's likely that there's going to be
some suffering in the on the grand scale
when we think about how human
civilization is going to work even if
you sort of add a utilitarian
sort of stint to this and you think oh
well maybe this particular generation
ship with
let's say
20 000 people probably not but let's say
20 000 people suffer on this generation
ship in order to facilitate a trillion
people on a new planet you go well like
that's a fair point
but
still uncomfortable for 20 000 people
for whatever 400 years
but you would maybe hope that they like
if you know you do the math on the on
the sort of trajectory and the mechanics
of space flight it would be about you
know 20 to 400 years or so hopefully
but what if you know those people on the
ship felt like they were you know the
chosen ones if you were the ones that
really were the vanguard of humanity and
were enabling an entirely new epoch and
and maybe they would be excited by it
and and i think you're right also
describing there again between 20 years
ago that 20 30 years ago it'd be really
hard to imagine having the totality of
all human culture on video like netflix
for example these ways where you can
watch almost any video that's ever made
or listen to any song that any human has
ever created and have that index and
with you
and you'd also still get updates because
you can still send of course radio waves
and generation ship and get the latest
episode of whatever comedy might be
coming out or something so you can still
get updates while you're traveling
farther from earth but you could be
pretty well entertained with vr you know
ar sort of systems if the transhumanists
get their way you're going to be able to
be in here too unforeseen states of
bliss constantly from the moment that
you're born until the moment that you
die and if all that you need to be is
this sort of vessel
to to continue human civilization or or
if david sinclair gets his way you only
need one generation
maybe two maybe two and that's not so
bad right yeah that would be fabulous um
yeah he just posted a picture earlier
today or he's uh he sent me a message
he's about some turtles so yeah
i've seen that as well he's on holiday
300 years old and he's uh you know so
there's precedent that life can live
pretty long i just humans have not quite
done it beyond 122 yet uh so i i um so i
mean again in the book it's very
conservative i make no assumptions that
we will live to be twice as long or that
we'll have you know fusion reactor
propulsion technology which would of
course make it shorter there's a lot of
things that would make it easier faster
shorter better uh but i just take what
we have what we know today and then run
with it so it's very conservative in
that regard i'd say how are we going to
get somewhere in 400 years what's the
propulsion technology that you put into
your models that exists
most of it's on either existing liquid
propulsion systems at least to get us to
orbit and off and running there's a
solar sail technology that over time you
know could pick up a fair amount of
speed
and there are some you could imagine
describe some of the the star star star
initiative or the the break uh
the the ability to like have lasers
basically shoot at a target and propel
you but that doesn't quite work yet but
it's cool idea um
so i describe all the options that are
currently but it'd probably be liquid
propulsion plus some solar sails uh
would get us
you know once you get up to speed
because those are speeds again that
exist today that we know we've had
probes like the parker solar probe uh
can actually get to a speed that would
get us to the closest star in about four
to five hundred years yeah has anyone
had sex in space yet do you know this
officially no unofficially a week and a
half
it's uh i think it's scott kelly told
you any rumors from up on the iss
i bet he has i bet he has there's
officially there has not been
neither confirmed or deny
uh any rumors of any kind but um
they do have private chambers
you know you gotta you gotta really
practice your moves but there's nowhere
to practice put in space you know so um
so officially space no one can hear you
sex but i mean obviously the um
what happens when you've got an embryo
growing into a fetus into a baby and a
birth in space
what are the challenges that i mean
is radiation a bigger concern for um
children in utero
that would be one of the key concerns we
i mean we know that
uh mice have been born in space so
pregnant mice have been sent up and then
pups have been born
human embryogenesis has proceeded out
for days so we know you can get to the
early stages and get towards say
gastrulation in early parts of
developing the embryo look like they
will work
but we've never had a whole beginning to
end embryogenesis towards birth of any
creature yet in space uh well as uh
there's been some uh drosophilas you
take that back so we know for example
they have been able to be born
invertebrate so but for a complex mammal
uh all the way from beginning to end
we think it should work based on the
data so far but we don't know yet like
especially when you get outside the van
allen belts and you go for a true
interstellar trip
the radiation is going to be a big
concern
but that being said if we have all the
tools
of molecular biology at our fingertips
and we could you know resist the
radiation tweak it modify the cells as
needed on the way
that might be one way to prevent some of
the damage or to repair it if it's
detected
what about social and mental issues in
space let's say that we're not doing the
transhumanism like just strap yourself
into an iv of mdma for
80 years and give birth like david
pierce is going to be upset but it
doesn't really matter um
what about social issues and anyone
that's read seven eves it's [ __ ] man
like yeah you know
the president ends up with a stake
between her her lip a
tongue and she can't speak and everyone
starts to end up being cannibals and
eating each other's legs soft
cannibalism they call it soft
cannibalism that that section of the
book freaked me out totally because but
i freaked out because it seemed
you know not too far from what might
actually happen if you put people in
these little capsules and say you're
stuck up there and we you might be able
to get somewhere in a few hundred years
and we're not sure and the the moon
exploded and the earth is being
bombarded and you can't even live on it
so we don't know
the the description of the book of the
social breakdown and just the cognitive
law and loss of being tethered to any
kind of reality it could vary it was
haunting because it seemed pretty pretty
probable like you're like well i could
really see this happening and also it
was a bit of a critique on the social
media world in which we live today is
that you can have people end up getting
so caught up in in concepts that they
lead them to do really insane things
like everybody eats their own likes
everyone likes because someone said it
was a good idea and say well okay maybe
that is a good idea and like nothing
else
or even like the pizzagate scandal the
guy who heard that there was a sex ring
that was at a dc pizza restaurant went
there with an assault rifle just because
he read about it and said i'm going to
go and start to threaten people with a
gun and you're like what's wrong with
you like how do you at some point you
know but but people you can't
underestimate um
the ability for people to get you know
to get lost to get uh confused to get
angry get frustrated
despondent and and it's more pronounced
in space for sure so i i think that is
one of the it's one listed as one of the
key hazards by nasa of long-term
spaceflight it's just this this
cognitive challenge and isolation uh
mathias bosner studies this a lot at
penn and he's you know we know it's it's
for sure a challenge that um you know
entertainment is one way to address it
mdma i'm not sure what you know we'll
need you know i talk a bit in the book
about games you know games are as old as
humans are so maybe think about like new
games that people can play with each
other
uh in flight uh some sort of space
football i'm not sure what it'll be but
it's one of the biggest challenges and
we'd have to either entertain people
keep them distracted
or somehow keep them sane but one of my
favorite examples of this is there's
these old underground cities in turkey a
lot of it was
even before the ottoman empire where
when there would be essentially wars
back and forth across the the you know
these steps of turkey people would go
underground and they'd you'd have these
huge underground cities so they could
hide from the army that was attacking
they'd have two three five thousand
people sometimes living underground but
with that when i did this tour a couple
years ago in turkey one out of every
about 10 rooms was actually a distillery
to make wine and the reason was because
they had to figure out some way just to
basically sedate the population so they
wouldn't go insane because they're all
living in caves for like two years
and i thought that was just you know for
a couple of years but you know so one
solution is just keep everyone drunk the
whole time we've tried that as humanity
before and it seemed to work in that
context
talk me through the mars expedition that
hopefully probably within what the next
maybe
20 years we're going to have boots on
mars
yeah by 20 20 35 20 33 maybe so soon
pretty soon
do you think that we are further ahead
technologically or further ahead
genetically
in terms of our preparation for this
like if the technology was available
right now could we go genetically and if
the gene if the genetics was available
right now could we go technologically
i think technology's ahead right now in
terms of um
we can definitely get there uh and the
landing would be hard there's of course
a really rough track record for for
anything that's been sent to mars a lot
of them have crashed or not made it it
is far away but the
jpl the group at nasa that designs a lot
of the rockets and rovers has done an
extraordinary job so i think we can get
there
land there and even survive there
but the genetic
deploying genetic technologies for
protection or novel therapeutics or
pharmaceutical agents are also really
being tested because we just have so
limited data there's only about 585
people that have ever been to space
including these new sub-orbital flights
right so it's really not that many
people and most of them we don't have
molecular data on right that's why it
was so exciting to write i called them
the first genetic astronauts because we
actually know what happened to them
genetically molecularly cellularly when
they went to space but before these
recent missions we did we just didn't
know so i think we're pretty far behind
but we'll catch up pretty fast if if all
goes according to plan there'll be a
private space station by 2024 by axiom
we can do really long term missions and
do entirely new science
there will be if all goes well by the
late 2030s a station around mars called
mars base camp by lockheed martin so
there might even be a ways to actually
have you know orbit rather than on the
earth on the surface on the surface in
orbit and it's planned so it's projected
we'll see if it happens but that is
planned right now
and you know i think in the next 10 20
years we'll see a lot more expansion
that's not just coming from russia and
the us in a cold war fighting each other
since but from
private industry many countries india
israel the uae as a orbiter of chinese
are really expanding quickly so i think
we have this space race 2.0 which has a
lot more players and a lot more tools
and the genetics will be part of that
ethically or politically or
socially or technologically is there
anything
that you're still concerned about are
there any sort of
real big questions that you haven't got
answers to yet with regards to
our potential to colonize the galaxy
i think
i i think it not nothing but i think
it's just a question of of will and of
of coordination i think we have a lot of
the tools that exist already some of
it's even just is framing it like even
the term colonizing the galaxy we
there's such a loaded word to colonize
and even settlement as a loaded word so
he's almost said like explore the galaxy
or to uh you know to to serve as
guardians or to expand life but it
effectively it's colonization but we
want to have all the good of
condensation which is just the exploring
part but remove all the parts that were
exploitative that were disruptive that
were destruct that were disruptive and
destructive that decimated entire
ecosystems you know brought pathogens um
we did the opposite of deontogenic
ethics right that basically just
destroyed everything in its path and so
what i'm excited about is i think we've
learned as a species right we have a
greater awareness and consciousness of
of how we deploy technologies and tools
not just on earth but also how we when
we go into space so i'm i'm i'm an
optimist because i think uh there's
evidence for it we've learned from it
infant mortality is lower than every
literacy is higher than ever by most
quantitative measures humanity's really
learning and doing better of course
we're heating the planet we have other
things we're doing that uh we're trying
to get a handle on uh with mixed success
but i think um we're even bringing
species back from extinction potentially
so we're even correcting injustices of
that we uh
bring a ferret back yeah the
black-footed so yeah we just sequenced
the genome of some of the clones uh last
couple weeks and confirming that they're
just as is as okay and genetically
diverse as some of the other ones and
what's amazing is a lot of times with
cloning you worry about lack of genetic
diversity but you can expand the
different diversity of the clones
actually you know we have a smaller
population size but it increased genetic
diversity with the tools of genetic
engineering so it's extraordinary as we
can begin to even
resolve and rectify some of the genetic
injustices of our species past uh you
have to do it carefully though because
if you bring a woolly mammoth back
uh
you know it might have problems we'll
probably do it on an island you know
could it not have been cooler than a
ferret
yeah like
first one come on
black-footed fairy tale we had we had a
surrogate don't we know with socks on
like i don't care
but if they're really cute you know the
cuteness back it was really
really
for the revive and restore project with
ben novak and all the team it's a great
group it's really it's it's conservation
brought to the molecular and genetic
level so i think that same ethos is
what's described a lot in into
deontogenic principles is that well what
what is our duty what is our our goal
and and what's a duty for our species
everyone the duties that you normally
have in life you could you could
abrogate or give up on like to a
marriage to a country to a family
uh but this is something i think is
actualized upon awareness that's an
inherent duty for our species
do you think that we are
spending too much or too little
attention on capturing galactic real
estate
um
[Music]
we're doing it it's slow so i think i
think that one of the big challenges the
space act prohibits people from owning
any land outside of earth uh including
the moon but it doesn't prohibit mining
it so you could actually create these
hollow
asteroids where you've mined everything
out and you didn't ever own it but you
extracted everything out of it and that
would still not violate the space you
know the outer space treaty i should say
uh and and so what's interesting is i
think the real estate so far is
prohibited but the uh extraction and
complete exploitation so far fine so i
think there's uh there's actually every
year the a harvard law harvard space law
meeting where you just talk about issues
in space law which is a small group of
lawyers but nonetheless uh are you
familiar with mara cortona do you know
who that is she's the director of the
astropolitics institute
she looks at the politics of space and
uh she's been on the show and like dude
i am fascinated by that by what does it
mean to own an area of space what does
it mean to yeah that that stuff's
amazing but i mean more than that i mean
in terms of the attention that's being
paid to um finding ourselves new places
to live by by going out into space it's
an easy critique to say there's lots of
injustices here on earth uh we can chew
gum and walk at the same time like
it's more than possible for us to do
multiple things but if you if you had a
god's eye view and you were able to move
some of the resources around do you
think that there is
more there should be more of an impetus
for us to to to apply pressure to this
dig even to find more exoplanets i mean
is it to find to do research for
propulsion to do research on genetics
should we be paying more attention or
are we paying the appropriate percentage
proportion of attention
i think we should pay more again i'm
biased because i'm a geneticist and a
space enthusiast and i just wrote a book
about this of course i think it should
be more but i think in proportion of
what we've done before the gdp for the
united states for example it used to be
almost five percent of the country's uh
assets were being spent on space
exploration space technology propulsion
and now it's about uh one-tenth of that
right and and so we know that you know
and you we know that we can do both
things for example the same time like we
uh passed uh the civil rights act of the
voting rights act uh in the 60s while we
were getting ready to go to the moon in
the united states and so we can make
social progress make it you know
economic progress while exploring the
universe so i i think we definitely can
walk and chew gum at the same time we
should ex you know invest more in it
because really the the the rainfall of
side effects from the technology that
you develop for space uh help medicine
they help uh local transportation help a
lot of industries because in space
you're forced to think in very small
spaces with very limited energy
it forces inefficiencies that helps
everything else you do at a terrestrial
scale so i think uh why not and there's
been a lot of
analyses of the economics of nasa and
how much money's been spent and it's
usually the estimate that it leads to
about you know one and a half to maybe
twofold for every dollar you spend you
get that dollar back either in a new
business a job that's created a
technology that's licensed some economic
output that is writ large goods so i i
think um you know there's probably some
things that are more inefficient than
others for any project and maybe some
are more productive than others but but
writ large
more investment would probably lead to a
lot of downstream uh downstream benefits
without question i'm sure you'll be
familiar with nick bostrom's thesis that
he says every second that we spend not
capturing the stars we're
losing forever
a
part of our bubble right we have this
expansion and it means that over time we
get less and less that we can have that
anders sandberg also working out of the
future of humanities institute his new
book which isn't going to come out until
next year is about how we would
landscape solar systems and different
galaxies by moving physically moving
stars and planets around so we're
getting towards sort of the real limits
of of what's possible at least in theory
i suppose our theories are at the limits
of what's possible and then you take
that to the nth degree you go
all the way to the very very very final
moments of the universe and make a
justification for why
changing the the fundamental substrate
that we are built on would be a good
idea just let's finish with that yep yep
and this in there was the depressing
part of the book again reading the very
end of the universe because i because it
begs the question you say okay you move
to a new star like well congratulations
but then the same thing is going to
happen to that start you go to the next
one the next one the next one onward to
another galaxy
inevitably you say well either the
universe is going to collapse back in
itself or there'll be a big rip or
there'll be you know a heat death an
entropy of the universe in some way the
universe at some point will end uh or
change in a way that we probably
wouldn't necessarily live through but i
make the argument that if we know for
example it's going to continually move
in on itself in a big crunch where all
the matter recoalesces
and maybe makes a new big bang what if
the next big bang the next version of
the universe the life doesn't emerge or
if it doesn't emerge in the next five
five hundred or a thousand
iterations of the universe what if what
if this is it what if this uniqueness of
life is really not just unique in this
universe but in all universes that ever
could be or will be
and so i make the case that if it's a
deontogenic question the uh answer is
clear you would prevent the the death of
the universe or the in any version of it
to preserve life and so you would if we
had the tools and the technology to
actually fundamentally restructure space
time
i think we should do so because there's
no guarantee that any anything else will
serve as a shepherd for the universe i
think if we could have a universe that
has an ability to make and preserve
universes that would be
something i think a universe would want
i kind of anthropomorphize the universes
but if i was a universe that's what i
would like right i'd say yeah
yeah that's a real big picture thinking
christopher mason ladies and gentlemen
uh the next 500 years engineering life
to reach new worlds will be linked in
the show notes below uh where else
should people go any other stuff that
you want to plug
uh there's a we have a twitter handle uh
at mason underscore labs on mason lab is
the lab at cornell also uh
it you know the this bought the books or
everywhere everywhere books are sold you
can get it obviously on like amazon and
barnes and noble and other websites mit
press and then um also i'd say you know
a lot of the work is on nasa's websites
for the exoplanets are fun to dig around
in and also on instagram
christopher.edu.mason but some of that
includes family random photos but uh
yeah my twitter feed is the most common
science beat i'd say i love it cheers
chris
thanks so much pleasure thank you very
much for tuning in if you enjoyed that
then press here for a selection of the
best clips from the podcast over the
last few months and don't forget to
subscribe makes me very happy indeed
peace